today's data shows that 1 million four
hundred and forty eight thousand and ten
tests for coronavirus have now been
carried out across Great Britain
including 69 thousand four hundred and
sixty-three tests carried out yesterday
two hundred and 1101 people have tested
positive that's an increase of six
thousand one hundred and eleven cases
since yesterday thirteen thousand six
hundred and fifteen people are currently
in hospital with coronavirus in Great
Britain down from thirteen thousand nine
hundred and twenty two yesterday and
sadly of those hospitalized with the
virus 30 thousand and seventy-six have
now died that's an increase of 649
fatalities since yesterday behind those
numbers are heartbreaking losses for the
loved ones of all those who've died and
once again our thoughts and our prayers
are with their friends and their
families professor Doyle will provide an
update on the latest data on coronavirus
but first as community secretary I'd
like to take this opportunity to give an
update on the work being done locally
during the pandemic to keep people safe
to provide support for people's jobs and
their businesses and to prepare for the
reopening and the recovery of our local
economies that's why it's appropriate
that this afternoon we're joined by
regional journalists who are doing so
much to keep people informed about how
the national effort is being coordinated
in our own communities a free country
needs a free press and the national the
regional and the local newspapers of our
country are under significant financial
pressure I'd like to echo the words of
the culture
secretary recently in encouraging
everyone who can to buy a newspaper as I
said before the battle against
coronavirus will be won in every city in
every town and every village across the
country this is truly a national effort
and it's a national effort taking place
at a local level my department
the minister of housing communities and
local government has played a vital role
in bringing people together to tackle
the virus we've provided local
authorities with over 3.2 billion pounds
during this pandemic so that they can
continue to support the communities that
need it through this most challenging
time and respond to the immediate
pressures they are facing due to
coronavirus whilst also protecting and
preserving vital public services at the
start of March I established a task
force to support local resilience forums
known as LRS standing them up at a local
level across the country to prepare each
and every community for a range of
different scenarios there are 38 lrf in
England which are made up of emergency
services a range of government agencies
health bodies and local authorities
they're headed by some of the most
senior and experienced local leaders of
the emergency services of councils the
NHS and others who together are leading
their communities through the crisis
with the full support of central
government recognising the unprecedented
challenge that we faced I took the
decision to embed within them some of
the finest military planners in the
world from our armed forces and I'm very
grateful for their hard work in recent
weeks
this combined expertise and leadership
is ensuring a comprehensive coordinated
and consistent response across the
country responding to the urgent need
for personal protective equipment to
reach the frontline of the care sector
we've mobilized
l ahrefs to help distribute PPE and thus
far they've delivered over 67 million
items in England alone since early April
together with local councils they're
also assisting us in supporting some of
the most vulnerable individuals in their
communities and to date they've helped
us to ensure that 1 million boxes of
food and essential supplies have now
been delivered to those people
identified by the NHS as extremely
clinically vulnerable to coronavirus the
shielded with more than two hundred and
ninety thousand boxes being distributed
every week this has been a huge team
effort and I'd like to take this
opportunity to thank everyone involved
for the role that they've played and
will play in the weeks ahead we're also
working very closely with mares to make
sure that we have a coordinated approach
to tackling coronavirus at a local level
the government has been determined to
ensure that the vital work of keeping
people safe in their homes also
continues so with the support of the
mayors of London of the Liverpool city
region of Greater Manchester of
Sheffield of the West Midlands and
others we were able to announce the
building safety pledge these mares have
come together because they have a number
of the high-rise buildings with highly
flammable cladding in their respective
regions and the pledge that we agreed
sends a very clear message that vital
building safety work must continue
despite the corona virus pandemic and
we've been joined by 25 local
authorities including 18 in London who
also given their fulsome support as work
on many of these critical sites was
paused early on it's now slowly starting
to reassume as a result of this
initiative and I would urge any building
owner or contractor to do so as soon as
practical where it's safe to begin work
once again now coronavirus will not stop
our mission to level up to unite and to
unleash the potential of this country
the Prime Minister will set out on
Sunday our approach to the second phase
of this pandemic and as we look ahead to
supporting businesses as they are able
to reopen my department will lead our
work on how our local economies can
adapt evolve recover and grow I will
continue to support mayors and local
government leaders who will play a
critical role in this work every local
economy now needs a plan to restart and
recover we will be informing these plans
with our own detailed work in areas such
as how work places from factories to
construction sites to offices can be
adapted how outdoor spaces leisure and
businesses from parks to high streets to
markets can be managed